I don't think I've ever had the
opportunity before to discuss in depth
eyebrows but part of een I mean they're
your signature thing I know the eyebrow
these ones are there they're the ones
that do one of the work very so you've
got you know you've got your eyebrows
Jake
they've worked very hard at those
eyebrows that grew into them over time
Amelia didn't your mother give you a pep
talk yeah
don't touch him that was the patch
exactly what my dad did never flight
they ever touch them they exactly
features yes mild is bullying at school
perfect totally wild
yeah your eyebrows are big
well that Arnie I know you've judged
bodybuilding brows too because I did not
welcome and I know but we have eyebrows
but you have eyebrows so I think you to
judge who has the best eyebrows now as
we vertical eyebrow off now we're
looking for precision movement rhythm
and definition so if you all start
flexing car you're gonna be on first
here we go music
take
talking about it
she so wants to win yeah yeah okay yeah
she's the best
one of the people who sadly didn't make
it was of course relate husband Khal
Drogo there's a whiff of : about there
we go well yes we under Graham Norton
Show and I have some as the LaVista boys